with us now bob woodson civil rights
icon and he's sick and tired of the
critical race theory poisoning our
schools and our public discourse
he and the 1776 unites initiative though
are fighting back
in a new book red white and black
rescuing american history from
revisionist race hustlers
uh it comes as the house democrats look
to ram through
a radical reparations bill bob woodson
joins me now
bob congrats on the book i have to ask
you
why is the left so adamant
in your mind what's their goal about
saturating
our schools with this race obsession
they really don't care about black
people they really are doing this
using the black uh experience and the
uh and our birth defect of race as a
bludgeon
to undermine the fundamental
institutions of our society
and they're doing this by promoting a
false narrative 1619
is a false narrative that paints america
as a slave tocracy and therefore all
whites
are benefit from racial privilege and
white supremacy and therefore
they must pay reparations and all black
people
are victims to be pitied and pampered
and so what we did since they were using
the the the issue of civil rights
and injustice we organize
28 outstanding scholars and activists
to offer a counter narrative to the lies
and falsehoods that are being
perpetrated in this
publication so we give an inspiration
and aspirational
challenge to their assumptions one of
those assumptions is that the
the the fourth the the one quarter of
blacks who are living in drug-infested
crime-ridden neighborhoods
that this is a legacy of slavery and jim
crow well in our essays we talk about
how blacks prospered in the presence of
jim crow
we built railroads we built homes we
built
businesses hotels medical schools 100
colleges
our essays have produced a curriculum
that we have released ten of those
lessons thus far
and have been 11 000 downloads on the
part of educators and others
seeking accurate and complete uh
accounting of american history so we're
excited we're challenging this narrative
but what they're doing uh laura is
really demeaning to black america
to assume that the that whatever change
or reform
that comes must be must burn from white
america
and there are reports tonight out of
chicago bob that mayor lori lightfoot i
know you two are pals
is only now granting one-on-one
interviews to black or brown
journalists
here again uh she's marginal i'm sorry
now is this is this what racial progress
looks like
you know they're using racism to conquer
racism
i mean we fought as we said we fought to
get white pigs away from the trough not
to replace them with black pigs we
fought
to get pigs away from the trough and
what they are doing
is so insulting and demeaning to black
america
the assumption is that unless and until
white people change
and and and reform there's a little we
we can do is if we have no
agency that we have no yeah no
understanding
your book is great thank you for writing
it and being here tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else